Herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast UFO, Folge 82, den wir mittlerweile schon präsentiert, wird das Ganze heute von Coca-Cola, Mhh Eat Fresh.
Gegenüber von mir sitzt Florentin Will. Herzlich willkommen, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, zu diesem neuen Folge, Fantastischen Podcast UFO. Wir heben ab, das haben wir nämlich jedes Mal vergessen, dass wir am Anfang... Anfang abheben? Ja. Ne, landen. Ach stimmt, jetzt landen wir erstmal. In der Menge ist passiert in der letzten Woche, wir haben jetzt eine Weile nicht aufgenommen, wir haben uns ein bisschen erholt, ein bisschen entspannt, wir sind ein bisschen angekommen, wir haben die Weihnachtstage so ein bisschen in unser Leben einziehen lassen. Stichwort Behaglichkeit, Hashtag Behaglichkeit. Ja, Hashtag der Woche, Hashtag Behaglichkeit, meine Damen und Herren, der Hashtag der Woche Behaglichkeit. Stefan ist im Behaglichkeitsmodus, das merkt man vor allem daran, dass er sich diese Wollmütze aufgesetzt hat. Stefan ist ja ein ganz anderer. Stefan, wenn man ihn sieht, man merkt natürlich, Stefan ist natürlich der klassische Pinsel. Lang, awkward, holzig, starr, ein bisschen steif und natürlich die Haare, die ihm natürlich dieses gewisse Etwas geben, die einen gewissen Abrundungseffekt haben. Und wenn da jetzt die Mütze drauf sitzt, es ist ein anderer Effekt einfach. Ich habe meine Mütze, eine Bommelmütze und ich finde das Wort Bommelmütütze beschreibt wie kein anderes Wort, das, was es eigentlich ist, Bommelmütze. Aber ist Bommel denn wirklich? Das ist tollpatschige Bommel. Aber Bommel ist auch so ein Wort, das sich einfach eingeprägt hat durch Benutzung, oder? Da ist doch nicht jemand Schneidermeister, der die Idee hatte, hat gesagt, das ist ja nicht Bommel, sondern es wird schon irgendwie so ein Rüschenklötz oder sowas haben. Man sagt auch wie so Dödel oder der Fries, und dadurch hat sich das so ein bisschen etabliert. Eine Uhr tickt, die tickt ja auch. Das hat ja auch irgendwie sowas mit so einem gewissen, also es macht ja ungefähr das nach, wonach es klingt. Verstehst du? Ah, du meinst Onomatopoesie? Onomatopoesie, richtig. Krachen. Und Bommel macht ja auch so ein bisschen, es Bommel bummelt halt so vor sich hin. Ja. Wenn man, wenn man, wenn man kein Wort hat, würde man auch sagen, dann Bömmel, Bömmelchen, Bömmelchen. Ja, Bömmel, ja, es bommelt schon so ein bisschen vor sich hin. Bömmel, hat Hitler auch mal so einen Tag, wo er einfach so eine Bommelmütze aufhatte, und dann ist er so lang gelaufen, er war ja nicht so groß, ist dann so lang gelaufen, irgendwie so oben zu seinem Obersalzberg, und dann ist die Bommelmütze halt so ein bisschen gebommelt. Ja, er hat wahrscheinlich relativ schnell gemerkt, dass das die Autorität so ein bisschen untergräbt. Warum überhaupt nicht? Gerade wenn man den Kopf schüttelt, einfach so dieser Bommel hinten dran. Das hat doch noch was viel subtileres, einen viel tieferen Charakter, wenn so ein Mann eine Bommelmütze aufhat. Ich weiß nicht, schon so ein bisschen und hat sie überlebt? Nein. Es kommt anders rüber, wenn hinten so ein Bommel hinten dran ist. Es ist einfach ein anderer Effekt. Das machen ja Ärzte manchmal, dass sie zu Weihnachten so eine Nikolausmütze tragen oder so. Oder ein Halloween. Ich glaube, das wurde relativ schnell wieder untergraben, wenn da so eine Klingel dran ist und man so reinkommt, klingelt, alle so yeah und er so nur so Krebs und oh. Ja, oder an Halloween so ein grosses Karzinom-Outfit oder so. Ja, ist auch schlecht. Mit grossen Niere, eine grosse Niere mit grossen Augen. Ja, sie haben leider Krebs. Und dann geht er raus, aber bleibt an der Tür hängen. Flontin, was geht bei dir im Moment vor? Es wird ein bisschen kälter draußen, für mich ist es ein bisschen zu kalt, es ist kalt draußen geworden, aber du hast trockene Haut, oder? Mach direkt die Haut kaputt. Ich habe trockene Haut. Ich weiß nicht, warum du dich so für meine Haut interessierst. Jeden Tag starrt Stefan irgendwie auf meine Haut und kontrolliert, ob nicht irgendwann...
Und die Haut im Gesicht? Im Gesicht ist die Haut so ein bisschen rau? Aber mit den Händen geht's, ne? Hände, Handhaut ist gut, Handhaut?
Ja, das ist ein längeres Thema jetzt.
Ellenbogenhaut?
Habe ich nie verstanden, warum Leute sich die Ellenbögen einkälen. Jucken, manchmal jucken die. Nee, bei mir gar nicht. Ich glaube, Ellenbogen ist das Körperteil, mit dem ich am wenigsten anfangen kann, zu dem ich am wenigsten Bezug habe. Das ist so per Definition von einem abgewandt, man kommt nicht ran irgendwie und es ist auch so ein, was ist das? Also das ist ja zwei Knochen, die sich irgendwie... Ich nenne es das Armknie. Ja, das Knie des Armes. Aber es ist für mich nicht wirklich greifbar, was das wirklich sein soll. Ich will damit auch gar nichts zu tun. Das ist wortwörtlich nicht greifbar. Ja, das ist nichts für mich. Wir haben, man muss sich als Marketingfirma ja heute auch viele einfallen lassen. Alle Werbeflächen sind belegt. Du kannst es irgendwie an der Wand klebt das Plakat. Ich verstehe, wo du hin bist. Im Radio, die Werbung über Ohren kommt die Radio rein, auf deinem Handy ist Werbung. Man muss sich als Werbefirma so ein bisschen überlegen, wo bringe ich meine Werbebotschaft noch unter, welcher Kanal ist noch offen? Herr Will, ich habe da eine Idee für neue Werbung. Ja, gerne, vielen Dank. Ellenbögen. Ja.
Wie wäre es, wenn wir einfach, weil die sieht man nicht so, die sieht man selber nicht. Sie haben leider nicht so eine große Visibilität. Aber wenn man hinter Leuten geht, in einer Fußgängerzone zum Beispiel, im Sommer, im Hochsommer, und dann wackeln die Ellenbogen von einem Ort zum anderen, und da könnte man dann auch mal irgendwie so groß draufschreiben, Kaufhof. Ja. Einfach über den Ellenbogen Kaufhof so. Dann geht man und sieht vor sich, sieht man dann jemanden, wo Kaufhof auf dem Ellenbogen steht. Da hat man schon Bock irgendwie. Auch warum sind die, ich finde die Rückseiten von T-Shirts, die sollten mal, da sollte dann gross S-Oliver draufstehen oder so. Vorne ist es mittlerweile völlig, da guckt man nicht mehr hin. Ja, wahrscheinlich, weil du es direkt mit dem Gesicht vergleichen kannst. Von hinten weißt du ja nicht, welche Person man ist. Aber tatsächlich, ich habe heute
einen Werbeversuch an mich herangetragen
bekommen, der mich sehr fasziniert hat.
Und zwar kann man, wenn man eine Facebook-Seite
hat, also nicht nur einen Account, sondern eine Seite,
die andere Leute liken können, wie zum Beispiel wenn man eine Band
hat, die mal bei X-Faktor war oder sowas in der Ecke,
dann kann man sich eine Like-Seite bauen
und da können andere Leute
Änderungsvorschläge einreichen.
Also wenn du irgendwie so ein Header-Bild hast, dann können die Leute sagen so, das ist scheiße, nimm doch ein anderes. Und da habe ich zum Beispiel heute auch, die Webseite von unserer Seite, podcast-ufe.fail, hat irgendjemandem nicht gefallen. Und da habe ich heute die Meldung bekommen, oh, jemand hat einen Änderungsvorschlag für unsere Webseite. Was war der Vorschlag? Und der Vorschlag war, dass wir doch unsere Webseite ändern sollen zu orgen.de.
Und das war deren Art, Werbung zu machen für die Seite.
Einfach das an Facebook-Seiten.
Aber kann man aus Versehen draufklicken, besitzt dann die Seite orgen.de.
Ja, das kann gut sein.
Da ist mit einem riesen Urheberrechtsstreit drin.
Ja, aber man klickt ja auf Bestätigen und dann steht da plötzlich, oh, die offizielleizielle Website ist organ.de. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch eine ganz geile Idee. Ich glaube, irgendein Social-Media-Praktikant hat da lange geschwitzt und sich überlegt, was kann man noch machen? Aber man kann ja auch bei Facebook Dinge erfragen. Wenn du bei Leuten nicht genau weißt, was bestimmte Informationen, die nicht ausgefüllt haben im Profil sind, kann man denen eine Anfrage schicken mit einem Klick. Da habe ich ich auch mal so Anfragen bekommen, so was ist meine Adresse von Leuten, mit denen ich nichts zu tun habe, das wäre das, ich finde es so seltsam, habe es weggeklickt, aber wenn diese Personen mich echt angeschrieben hätten und gefragt haben, hör mal, was ist eigentlich deine Adresse, dann fände ich das so gruselig, aber darüber geht es, man ignoriert das so ein bisschen. Ich wollte schon so oft bei klassisch bei Beziehungsstatus natürlich, man stalkt irgendjemanden, den man auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt
gesehen hat und irgendwie gerade in seine
Käsewurst gebissen hat und dann denkt man sich,
stalkt man die auf Facebook, dann sieht man die und dann
Relationshipsstatus offen, nicht benannt
und dann ask, ja?
Und dann denkt man sich auch so, das ist die
womöglich unsubtilste Art
auf jemanden zuzugehen, so
bist du Single oder nicht?
Unsubtilter wäre es, die anzuschreiben, ich finde, so ist es noch so ein bisschen subtiler. Aber es ist so ganz technisch. Ja, es ist ganz technisch. Aber man fragt dann nicht nur Beziehungsstatus, sondern noch so ein paar Alibi-Fragen. Hey, was ist dein Lieblingsfilm? Auf welche Konzerte gehst du noch so ein Freund? Und was ist so dein Tier-Sternzeichen und so? Man fragt dann so ein paar andere Sachen. Ja, oder einfach nur, also eigentlich ist es ein grosses, in Eins und Nullen verpacktes Frage, ob sie Interesse an einem hat. Ja, im Grunde schon. Eins, Null, Null, Null, Null, Null, Null, Null, Null, Null, Null, Null, Null. Aber ich dachte mir auch mal ganz lange, wo man auch beim Turmspringen und so, das fand ich ganz interessant, wo wir gerade bei Werbung waren, wo die dann auf ihrem Körper halt Werbung hatten. Echt? So mit Tattoo oder was? Ja, beim TV-Total-Tum-Springen hatten die halt auf ihrem Körper verschiedene Tattoos und so. Ach was. Und haben Werbung für Aida und sowas gemacht. Für Tattoo-Entfernung.de. Ja. Und da dachte ich mir, was, da setzt die Messlatte für Werbung komplett in andere Sphären. Und da dachte ich mir, warum nicht im Zoo auf Schildkröten zum Beispiel. Auf Schildkröten? Einfach so Obi. Ja. Auf eine Schildkröte, weil die laufen nicht so langsam, die haben diesen grossen runden Panzer, wo man einfach so gross Kaufland oder so drauf machen könne. Netto. Und dann laufen die einfach da rum und man denkt die ganze Zeit, da hat mir noch was vor, ich muss noch einkaufen gehen, wo gehe ich hier netto natürlich. Oder diese Dinosaurier damals, die mit diesem grossen Kamm. Ja, perfekt. Die sehen aus wie so Kundenfänger Fussgangs-Zonen. Oder diese Wagen, die manchmal rumfahren, wo Werbung hinten draufsteht oder so ein Schild. Das wäre die perfekte Werbefläche gewesen für andere Dinosaurier. Was ist los mit diesen Wagen, wo nur so ein Werbeschild hinten draufsteht? Ist das ein Privatwagen? Die fahren in der Stadt rum. Ja, aber die fahren einfach nur dumm durch die Gegend, oder was? Ja. Das kann doch nicht wahr sein.
Doch! Der Job von dem Typen ist es,
den ganzen Tag wirre durch die
Stadt zu fahren und dann
neben fetten Leuten stehen zu bleiben mit der
Snickers-Werbung und dann fährt die Werbung so ganz
langsam neben dem fetten Typen
mit der so bobb, bobb, bobb, bobb,
bobb, und er immer so nebenbei
so, ich hab schwere Knochen.
Und der Typ im Auto immer so, na, na, hier, Bock. Das ist echt tatsächlich, also als ich noch... Oder auch so die Brille so runternehmen und so angucken, so nach dem Motto, wir wissen beide, dass es was wir sehen. Ja, genau. Wir wissen beide, dass sie die Werbung nicht brauchen. Es wird passieren, die Frage ist nur jetzt oder später, lieber jetzt. Ist aber tatsächlich so, wenn du, ich weiß noch, als ich fett war, als ich so richtig so ein fettiger Fettwurstmann war. Versuch, kannst du einen Ball darzustellen. Die Weihnachtskugel, die menschliche Weihnachtskugel. Ja, aber dann ist man so durch die Stadt gelaufen und dann hast du so einen Typen, so dieser klassische, also so einen klassischen türkischen Basar, wo man unterwegs ist und dann gibt's den Nougatmann, ja. Dann hast du so einen Typen, der hat einen Stand aus Nougat, ja. Und einfach weiss das Nougat... Moment, warat-Mann gerade ein ganz, ganz fieser Ausdruck für den afro-amerikanischen Mitbewerber? Nein, einfach, nee, nee, nee, der verkauft Nougat, so weisses Nougat, nee doch schon Nougat, ja, weisses Nougat, schwarzes Nougat, braunes Nougat, so alle Regenbogenfarben stehen da und Nougat ist ja einfach pure Kalorien einfach. Und wer sich einfach so puren Nougat in sein Mundloch reinschiebt, der hat eigentlich eh schon verloren. Ja. Und er einfach sagt so, nee, nicht Nougat Schokolade. Ich kann auch Butter mit dem Löffel essen. Ja, nicht Nougat Schokolade, nicht irgendwie Marzipan mit Nougat, sondern einfach nur Nougat. Und da läuft man vorbei als fetter Mensch und der Typ nickt einem so zu, so Wissen so. Nimm's schon. Und dann nimmt er auch so mit der puren Hand, nimmt er so ein Stück Nougat und wirft es hinterher. Wie wirklich so? so? Aber du kannst auch nicht wegrennen, wenn du fett bist. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Ja, und du natürlich leckst es dann vom Boden. Natürlich. Aber das war bei mir als Fettwanst immer so ein Moment, wo ich so dachte so, nee, das gönne ich dir jetzt nicht, du Schwein. So dass du mir so als von allen Menschen, die da vorbeilaufen, von allen schönen Frauen, von allen Kindern und alten Leuten, dass du dir genau mit deinem Terminator-Blick aus der Masse so den Fettsack rausholst und dem so zunigst, so diesen, na, Bock auf ein Milchshake und du so ja, aber ich will bei diesen XXL-Läden auch immer so geil, wenn du als Fettwanz auf den XXL-Laden zulässt, dann aber nebenan doch ins normale H&M reingehst und dann so der Verkäufer schon vom Laden steht und nicht so und dann von der von der Aussensicht und fünf Minuten später wieder der Walk of Shame. Und dann in den anderen Laden reingehst. Der Walk of Shame. Aber das ist auch so eine Sache. Da war neulich mal Werbung für ein XXL-Zalando im Internet. Und da war die Werbung, das Testimonial war ein Basketballspieler. Und er meinte so, ja, mein Name ist Vanga Burgiswan und ich bin 2,30 m gross und ich kann nicht in den normalen Laden gehen, also gehe ich zu xxlshop.de.
Und dann dachte ich mir, hm, auch ich bin zwei Meter achtzig gross, warum nicht mal da reingucken und einfach lange T-Shirts, ich liebe lange T-Shirts, weil ich das so selten habe und so selten finde, meine T-Shirts sind immer ein bisschen zu kurz, ich sehe immer so wie ein bauchfreier Typ, der sehr kurze Shirts hat, einfach kurze Shirts. Du hast schon ganze Trends generiert, auch so diese kurzen T-Shirts und diese kurzen Hosen, die man jetzt geträgt, alle von Stefan Tietze angefangen, einfach weil es zu kurz war. Ja, auch diese hässliche Brille hat alles Stefan. Okay, alles klar. Und dann war ich in diesem Laden und dann hatten die nur Dinge, die in die Breite gehen. Das heißt, die haben mit diesem Basketballer die komplett falsche Zielgruppe angesprochen. Weil das ist ein Athlet, das ist ein Sportler, der ist ganz anders gebaut als die Zielgruppe von xxlshop.de. Warum nehmen die nicht einfach so Rainer Karlmund, die lassen die da hin und sagen, boah, also, man spricht ja auch dann anders als Vetter, wenn ihr
Scheiß braucht, dann geht dahin, aber dann
nehmt ihr so einen langen Basketballer. Warum,
wo ist denn deine Idee dahinter? Das ist schwierig, ne?
Weiß ich nicht, es gab keine Sachen für lange Leute,
es gab nur für sehr dicke Leute.
Aber das ist echt der größte Walk of Shame,
oder auch der Walk of Shame ist auch,
ich glaube, so die Top 5 Walk of
Shames. Die Top 5
Walk of Shames! Platz Nummer 5, Als Kind in der Erwachsenenabteilung Kleider einkaufen. Klassisch, sich schön auf die Rolltreppe stellen. Doch, kenne ich ganz gut. Auf die Rolltreppe stellen und sagen, ich bin viel zu jung und mir passt das alles in die Länge überhaupt nicht, aber ich bin so fett. Hier muss was für mich gefunden werden. Das ist wirklich das Allerschlimmste. Platz Nummer vier,
auch, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt, aber
gibt's,
gab's früher immer
in München, ich war jetzt Kind in München unterwegs, und da gibt's
zwei Läden, die eine Rutsche haben.
Und zwar gab's immer den,
ja, Marketing hat gut
funktioniert, so einen Schulladen,
und dann gab's noch den, den, den
O-Blätter am Stachus. Und da gab's früher, das war so ein Spielzeugladen, und gab es noch den O-Blätter am Stachus
und da gab es früher, es war so ein Spielzeugladen
und da gab es auch eine Rutsche
und die Rutsche ist mittlerweile gesperrt,
die Rutsche gibt es immer noch, aber da sind lauter
Bälle drin und da kann man nicht mehr drin rutschen sein,
da werden Bälle verkauft und da habe ich
auch mal gehört, die Rutsche wurde gesperrt,
weil da ein Kind gestorben ist.
Und das ist halt wirklich die harmloseste Rutsche der Welt,
also wirklich so eine ganz leichte Neigung, wenn du nicht gerade wie ich immer mit Butter eingeschmiert warst, kommst du da sowieso nicht voran. Und da stehst du nicht. Und da war auch der Walk of Shame so als Kind, so du rennst zur Rutsche, setz dich rein und du merkst, nope, ich bin zu fett, ich werde mich hier drin nicht bewegen können. Das ist einfach zu klein. Und dann auszusteigen und die Treppe runterzulaufen. Ja, exakt. Neben allen anderen Kindern, die runterrutschen. Ich bin im Spaß bei der Treppe hochgelaufen, es war aber schon kurz vor sechs, also kurz vor, mach zu, bin nach oben, die Ampel sprang auf rot, als sie oben angegangen war, und bin die Wendeltreppe wieder zehn Minuten lang runtergelaufen, weil die halt zu war. Das ist der Nummer drei Walk of Shame, auf den Fünfer hochzugehen und dann wirklich, und sich neben allen vorbeizudrängen. Ach, das ist doch ziemlich hoch. Hui, und dann wieder runtergehen. Ja, ja, vor allem alle anderen stehen ja auch wirklich ganz nah aneinander und wollen da hoch. Und diese Leitern sind nicht dafür ausgelegt, dass zwei Leute nebeneinander stehen können. Deswegen musst du dich so durchdrängeln, so alle gucken dich an und sehen dich und sehen, nee, da bringst du dich. Auch ein Walk of Shame, ich weiß nicht, ob es Platz zwei wert ist, aber eine zu enge Hose nehmen und dann zu faul sein, seine Hose wieder anzuziehen und in den Laden zu gehen, sondern mit der zu kleinen Hose, die offensichtlich viel zu klein ist, wo man alles sieht, Knie, Waden, so mega eng, die offen ist oben und dann einfach wieder in den Laden geht und sich die grössere Nummer rausnimmt und dann wieder zurück in die Kabine geht. Auf jeden Fall Platz zwei. Das stimmt. Platz eins, Florentin? Wenn man eine Top-Fünf-Liste aufmacht und keinen Platz eins hat. Sehr gut. Auf shame Nummer eins. War of shame, das spricht für mich. War of shame. Wir haben jetzt aber übrigens, weil Florentin, muss man sagen, wird wieder fetter. Ich habe ein Bild gesehen von einem halben Jahr von dir. Wow, schlank, attraktiv, man sieht die Wangenknochen mal, hat Florent die Wangenknochen, ja, hat er, und
jetzt ist die wieder weg, einfach so,
haben die Luft aufgelöst, und deswegen führen wir jetzt ein
Essens-Tagebuch. Ich bin Ernährungsberater meinerseits
und fühle mich da auch in der Pflicht,
ein bisschen darauf zu achten, dass du
ein bisschen dich in die richtige Richtung entwickelst.
Wir haben hier, Florentin am
23.11. zwei Bounty,
muss das sein,
weiß ich nicht, Cola-Fläschchen. Naja, Moment mal, das möchte ich kurz erklären. Es ist ja auch immer so ein psychologisches Ding. Du gehst nach dem Essen, hast du einfach Bock auf was Süsses, gehst schön zum Snackbär und holst dir ein Bounty. Ja, Klassiker. Dann, Tarkan der Spack sagt noch, hey, ich gehe zum Snackbär und soll dich immer was mitbringen. Und dann sagt sie natürlich, na klar, bring mir ein Bounty mit. Ja, dann bringst du immer ein Bounty mit. Warum so viel Bounty? Ja, wenn du die Shorts hast, klar. klar. Du hast ja immer erst ein Bounty in mein Mundloch geschoben, dann musst du dir nicht schon wieder ein Bounty in Auftrag geben. Ich kann da nicht nein sagen. Für mich ist, wenn jemand mir das anbietet, dann nehme ich das auch. Zwei Bounty, dann ein Cola-Fläschchen, warum kann es nicht ein Wasser sein, Glas Wasser, hm? Ihr müsst euch vorstellen, wie ich gerade vorwas von meiner Bommelmütze wähle. Dann ein Sojagurt-Joghurt, Mandel. Okay. Ja, der ist okay, der hat nicht viel. Der ist okay, hat nicht so viel. Edamame, auch okay. Das sind nur Böhnchen. Das sind Erbsenscholen. Ja, sowas in der Richtung. Spinat mit Erdnusssoße und sechs Sushi-Dinger und eine Banane hinten dran noch. Ja. Ja gut, aber man kann auch sagen, entweder Banane oder zwei Bounty oder halt. Ach komm, das ist aber nicht so schlimm, oder? Sushi ist nicht so schlimm. 24.11. Acht Buffetgänge. Ja gut, aber das war ein kleiner Teller. Das war ein kleiner Teller. Acht Buffetgänge, 19 Nippon, das sind wir gegessen, eine Kirschtasche, ein Lebkuchenmännchen und ein Brezel. Das war am 24.11. los. Und das ist nur die Zeit, in der wir zusammen sind, morgens und abends. Und am Wochenende habe ich nur irgendwann bei 13 Nutella-Croissants habe ich irgendwann auch aufgehört zu zählen und dann kamen auch keine Meldungen mehr, weil er erstmal in Koma angesagt war, glaube ich. Am Wochenende kam dann irgendwann gar nichts mehr, obwohl wir abgemacht haben, dass du mir immer schicken sollst, was du gegessen hast. Kam da irgendwann aus Scham nichts. Ja, es stimmt schon, ich bin schwach und es wird mir auch nicht besser.
Es ist einfach schlimm.
Das war das Florentins Essensnagebuch.
Fatshaming!
Er hat sich so mit Essen.
Ja.
Ja, Fatshaming. Ah, nicht schlecht.
Aber, obwohl wir gerade bei Florentins Leben sind, heute die große Florentin-Folge.
Ja.
Du hast dir ein Digitalpiano bestellt und ich finde das toll.
Ja, es stimmt.
Du gehst unter den Musikanten, du klimperst ein bisschen in meinem Haus rum, du hast dir eins geholt, wo ich sehr dankbar bin, im Namen von allen Nachbarn, mit einem Klinkenstecker, du kannst über Mikrofon hören. Genau, da auch nochmal ganz herzliche Grüße an, vielleicht finde ich ihn auf Anhieb, einen netten Hörer, der mir geschickt hat einen Hinweis und zwar auf eine Technologie, die sich silent... Ein Hinweis, ein Hinweis, ein Eis, Ein Eis? Ach nein. Hier, Josephine, Josephine, äh, et expletivum hat mir geschrieben, äh, et pomis ruppel, und dann finde ich auch sehr schön, ernst gemeinte Lösung deines Klavierproblems, weil... Dankeschön! Vielen Dank, Josephine, und auch vielen Dank, dass du die Einsendungen, die an mich so in deine Regel kommen, richtig einschätzt, zu 95 Prozent kompletter Bullshit, komplett unbrauchbar, ich hab keine Ahnung, worum es geht, oft schicken mir Leute so Ausschnitten aus Videos und nur so ein Lachsmiley und dann irgendwie so ein Ausschnitt aus einer zwölfstündigen Doku und bei Stunde acht, Minute vierzehn oder so dann so den Timer getrackt bei dem Link und dann klickst du da drauf und passiert irgendwas und okay, ist das jetzt eine Anspielung auf irgendwas, was ich jemals gesagt habe? Keine Ahnung. Aber manchmal, das unterdecken ja gerade speziell bei Spotify, viele neue Leute, viele neue Hörer. Und manchmal glauben die, dass man sich an alles erinnern kann, was man in dieser Zeit gesagt hat. Und dann kommt so, boah, wie ihr in Folge 2 über die Schiefertafel gesprochen habt, das war megageil. Und ich denke mal die ganze Zeit so, das klingt so ganz seltsam, so ganz andere Welten. Ich habe auch vor, gehen auch Leute zu John Williams und sagen dem so, ja, das war geil, also damals bei dem einen Film dieses, das war grossartig. Und dann will ich sagen, wir sind so genial wie John Williams. Genau, aber es klingt natürlich so ein bisschen arrogant, aber es ist auch dann Leute so, ey, ihr habt ja in Folge vier gesagt, wir sollen euch schreiben, ob wir Mandeln mögen. Ja, ich mag Mandeln.
So, alles klar, cool, danke schön. Ich kann mich nicht mehr im Ansatz an irgendwas daran nennen, aber vielen Dank dafür, wir lieben jede Post.
Aber Josephine hat mir auch geschrieben, Silent Piano, eine Technologie hat sie mir geschickt, die es ermöglicht, ein Klavier in einen Silent Piano zu verwandeln, so dass man nichts mehr hört, weil irgendwie die, äh, diese Hämmer, die auf die Saiten hauen, ersetzt werden durch irgendwelche digitalen Abtaster oder sowas. Vielen Dank, dafür ist aber nicht mehr nötig, denn ich habe mir in der Zwischenzeit ein Digital Piano bestellt. Yeah, der ganz leise Yamaha. Ich habe mir lange überlegt, ob ich es machen soll.
Bei mir ist es immer so, ich will was, also auch vielleicht ein kleiner Tipp an dich,
vielleicht auch für die Leute da draußen, ich will was und dann schreibe ich mir das in den Kalender und sag mir, okay, heute ist der Tag, ich will Digitalpiano und dann stelle ich mir einen Wecker für in zwei Wochen und wenn ich es in zwei Wochen immer noch will, dann kaufe ich es. Sehr guter Tipp. So, nicht hundertprozentig treu geblieben, weil ich habe nach einer Woche schon angefangen, Klaviernoten zu bestellen und hatte dann schon Noten und habe dann gesagt, soll ich mir jetzt noch ein Klavier kaufen? Ja! Und habe es mir dann auch geholt.
Aber es wird sehr interessant und es wird bald angeliefert und da wird bestimmt eine tolle Anekdote folgen, ich teaser jetzt schon mal, weil das Ding ist so fucking schwer und wird nur an die Bordsteinkante geliefert und ich muss es dann auch in den dritten Stock tragen und ich wollte dann so da anrufen und sage so ja, ja, ja, ja, aber wenn die das dann liefern, kann ich denen dann auch so 20 Euro geben, dass sie mir das in den dritten Stock tragen oder so, also ich wollte das nicht so fragen, so dieses, ist es respektlos, das ist genauso wie wenn man bei einer Massage anruft und sagt so, für ein Zwanni würden sie mir nochmal schön meine Hohnen streicheln oder Hunni oder nicht oder so, also das war ein Stand-up-Bit, das war ein kleiner Test. Mehr davon können wir im Stand-up erfahren. Aber man will ja so ein bisschen vorfühlen, man weiß ja nicht, ob das dann respektlos der Person gegenüber ist. Deswegen habe ich das nicht gemacht, es wird auf jeden Fall interessant, aber mal gucken und dann kann ich ja, und dann werde ich auf jeden Fall, weil das ist total abgefahren, das hat ganz viele Funktionen und das kann auch aufnehmen so. Und dann werde ich euch mal ein Stück. Aber warum hast du so ein schweres Dingeln bestellt? Es sind doch mega geile Stage-Pianos. Ja, ich will aber auch Pedale, ich will pedalieren. Kannst du auch pedalieren damit? Ja, ich will aber so, ich will auch was hermacht. Ich will so ein schmuckes Ding. Ich will so, das war ja auch die Idee von der PS4, dass es nicht nur, also eine Playstation an sich, dass es nicht nur eine Konsole ist, sondern auch ein Möbelstück. Es ist so Klavierlack und es hat sowas schwarze und es ist ansehnlich
und es sieht erwachsen aus und man will auch so ein Ding
rumstehen haben. Ich habe eh nichts in meinem Zimmer.
Gar nichts. Deswegen kann ich das auch
gut gebrauchen und unterbringen.
Das ist eine Katze, die da jetzt tot rumliegt,
weil die gerade am Sterben ist, wie du gerade gesagt hast.
Das ist ein Thema, über das möchte ich nicht reden, das ist ein anderes Thema.
Meine Katze, die mir meinen Fischposter
runtergerissen hat, das Biest.
Und alles, sowieso alles kaputt macht, was ich irgendwo an die Wand hänge, deswegen bin ich mit dem Blavier echt safe. Aber ich werde euch was einspielen, ich werde euch was kleines einspielen und dann kann ich ja ein kleines Soundpipe mitbringen. Nee, wir können das mal machen, dass du eine Folge scorest, also dass wir hier sprechen. Boah, das wird aber glaube ich so viel bei... Mega schwer, mega nervig, ab Minute, übrigens, vielleicht erinnern sich manche Hörer an die Folge 13 mit der Ukulelen-Folge, wo wir das Ganze mit der Ukulele, mega nervig irgendwann, aber kann man ja machen, ich freue mich drauf. Wie zum Beispiel ein Podcast, der das macht, ist Spontane Nation, falls ihr Bock habt auf neue Podcasts, Tompkins interviewt erst einen Gast und improvisiert dann mit ihm Zähnen. Lustige Geschichte, ich höre Podcasts immer beim Einschlafen und ich höre oft Spontane Nation, ich bin noch nie bis zum Impro-Teil gekommen, never. Ja, das dauert tatsächlich ein bisschen. Never, weil ich schlafe ein, bevor das kommt, ich höre das ganze Interview, was auch schon manchmal lustig ist, muss ich auch schon manchmal verschmunzeln, und dann mache ich immer aus, weil ich dann einschlafe oder so, aber dann höre ich mir doch nicht nochmal alles an, um dann zum Impro-Teil zu kommen. Ja, das stimmt. Und ich kann auch nicht beim Impro-Teil anfangen, weil ich davor das alles vergessen habe. Der erwartet dabei, dass du zwei Stunden nach einem Stück Podcast hörst. Das macht doch niemand. Aber es ist auch erstaunlich, weil da werden nicht immer nur Comedians interviewt, sondern auch manchmal einfach so Schauspiele, so Walking Dead der Asiate oder so war da, ist da dabei. Und es sind jetzt keine Comedians oder ausgebildete Improvisateure oder sowas, aber die sind trotzdem immer echt lustig in den Improszenen. Also das Also das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Ich schneide davon mal eine Scheibe ab. Ja, dankeschön. Aber auch da, wo man sich denkt, so deutsche Leute, die man einladen kann, irgendwie selbst Comedians, wo man nicht weiß in so einer Impro-Szene, ob die das hinkriegen würden. Ich meine, Impro hat in Deutschland keine Grundlage und keine Kultur, aber trotzdem. Ich finde es immer wieder erstaunlich, wie lustig Amerikaner irgendwie sind. Ja, die sind sehr lustig. Das ist echt abgefahren. Die sind echt lustig. Ich war am Wochenende in Berlin, deiner Heimatstadt. Ah, Berlin. Da wurde ein Herz lebt. Ah, dickes B. Berlin, Berlin. Ah, ein Traum. Da hab ich mich noch nicht gefragt. Ich hab nämlich eine alte Dokumentation über Berlin gesehen. Und der Sprecher spricht die ganze Zeit so. Berlin, Berlin, Riesenstadt Berlin. Warum? Also, weil heutzutage ist der beste Sprecher jemand, der so spricht. Auch wenn ein Auto kennt man ja, diesen tiefen schön bitte ein bitte. Das ist der beste Sprecher, tief, langsam, überprononziert. Ja, ja, ja. Aber der damalige beste Sprecher und dachte, was machen sie zum Beruf? Ja, na gut! Und dann diese ganz enge, sehr, sehr aggressive, spitze Stimme.
Kann es einen technischen Hintergrund haben? Hab ich auch gedacht, ja. Wahrscheinlich technisch, weil man dachte, weil man den besten durchkommen. Also weil niemand diese Bass aufnehmen kann.
Wahrscheinlich die Frequenzen oder so, ja, das kann schon sein.
Aber haben die tief gesprochen? Hatten die im echten, ich mich vor allem, hatten die damaligen Sprecher im echten Leben eine angenehme Sprechstimme und dachte man, den den hört man auf 18 Meilen Entfernung. Komm, komm in die Sprecherkabine und sprich mal hier den Text ein. Berlin, Berlin, Riesenstadt Berlin. Heutzutage ist ja so die Authentizität immer so als enorm grosser Wert da. Irgendwie so im Fernsehen sagt man, ah, der ist authentisch, den mag ich. Oder auch so bei Podcastern, die reden ja so authentisch. Ich glaube, das ist ein recht neuer, überhaupt positiv Wert, dass irgendwas authentisch ist. Ich glaube, früher war es eher so, man setzt eine Maske auf, wenn man vor der Kamera ist. Natürlich, weil wer will den Depp sehen? Auch wenn die moderiert haben, die Leute damals. Ja, aber auch so im Radio. Und jetzt hören wir die Band, die jeder gerne mal mag und die da gerne mal sehen will. Wir freuen uns auf die Beach Boys. Viel Spaß. Ja, absolut. Aber auch so bei Aristoteles oder so, auch so Rhetorik oder so, da war ganz... Mein Gott, ey, wir müssen uns nicht mal dummer stellen, als wir sind. Da war es auch so, dass die gesagt haben, okay, Redner irgendwie, klar, es ist eine ganz andere Figur, Stilmittel irgendwie und die kannte man auch und die kannten die Zuhörer auch und es war irgendwie so eine Kunst des Redens und ob der authentisch ist oder nicht, scheißegal, so der hatte eine Meinung zu vertreten und es war sein Auftrag und das hat er gemacht. Man könnte sagen, erst mit Brecht fing das an, das epische Theater, da mal zu sagen, man bricht mit dieser Maske gerade auf. Nein, das hat mit Unge angefangen. Mit Unge, einfach ein authentischer, echter Entertainer, der vor der Kamera steht und sein eigenes Leben zeigt. Und man auch, ja dieser Switch in der Rolle des Entertainers, also diese ganzen YouTuber, die wir heute sehen, man sagt dann immer, die bereiten sich ja gar nicht vor, die sind ja gar nicht lustig, aber das ist ja auch gar nicht die Anforderung. Das ist einfach nur geteiltes Sozialleben, weil die Kinder treffen sich heutzutage nicht mehr, sondern haben einfach ihre Freunde, sind die Leute im Internet. Und die erzählen dann halt so, ja, ich will heute einkaufen und ich hab mich mit dem Moni getroffen. Das, was man sich mit ihren Freunden erzählen würden, erzählt ihnen halt Unge. Und wenn man da so mit so einer Entertainersicht und mit so einer Fernsehproduzentensicht drauf so sagt, ja, das ist ja alles trivial, dann verfehlt man den Punkt, weil es ist kein Entertainer. Weil darum geht es nicht. Es geht einfach nur um ausgelagerte soziale Stimme. Die wollen, die spielen zusammen Minecraft, die zocken im Internet zusammen. Genau. Das ist cool. Und du erwartest von deinen Freunden ja auch nicht die Megalines oder die tollen Referenzen, sondern einfach eine gute Zeit. Aber ist es nicht der falsche Weg, sich in so eine unpersönliche Freundschaft zu entwickeln, die speziell für Unge auch falsch fälschlich verstanden werden kann? Er denkt, er hätte tausend Freunde, aber eigentlich ist er ganz allein. Eigentlich ist Unge alleine in Minecraft. Diese ganzen kleinen Männchen, diese kleinen zweidimensionalen Männchen, die darumdödeln. Sind das Freunde? Kann das ein Freund ersetzen? Leute, die good game oder hi schreiben am Anfang, dann am Ende schreiben bye, danach zwischendurch schreiben gg. Sind das Leute, die dich weiterbringen im Leben, mit denen du die Erfahrungen durchleben kannst? Das klingt jetzt nicht so progressiv. Naja, es ist ja die Frage, ob er sich nicht auch als Projektionsfläche sieht, die er ja ist. Ja, ich ja ist. Also ich weiß nicht, ob du jetzt als Pornostar dir auch denkst, oh, ich bin die attraktivste Frau der Welt, weil denen ist ja auch klar, dass es im Endeffekt scheißegal ist. Du brauchst halt nur gewisse Features, zu denen du dir einen runterholst, aber das heißt jetzt nicht unbedingt, dass du die begehrenswerteste Frau bist, weil es ist einfach nur eine Projektionsfläche deiner Fantasie und du nur so ein Model bist, wo dann im Endeffekt entweder in der Mode dann die Kleider dranhängen. Ich finde es gut, dass du, wenn du über dich als Pornodarsteller sprichst, von dir als Frau sprichst. Ach so, nee, ich dachte jetzt die, die ich konsumiere, aber ja. Ach so. Ja, ich weiß es nicht. Was konsumierst du so für Pornos? Midget. Midget. Helicopter Midget. Ja, klar. Fuck's not his father. Helicopter Midget. Medit, Helikopter-Midget, fucks not his father. Helikopter-Midget, Midget, Midget on Midget, Midget climbing into giant vagina, Large Midget, Midget with medium-sized dick. I love those medium-sized Midgets. I love Midgets. Love them. Warum gibt es eigentlich nicht die Umkehrung von midget?
Ich meine, wenn es eine Hormonstörung gibt, dass man kleiner ist, warum gibt es nicht das Gleiche in die andere Richtung, dass man halt grösser ist?
Ja, hab ich ja.
Naja, aber du bist ja noch normal, du bist ja gross.
Ich bin sehr gross.
Du bist ein grosser, normaler.
Es gibt auch Unterschiede zwischen kleinen Menschen und midgets.
Aber es gibt Riesenwuchs, es gibt Riesenwuchs, aber das hört irgendwann bei der Grösse auf und geht dann mehr in so Gliedmassen über.
Das heißt, die haben dann sehr vorstehende Augenbrauen und so sehr vorstehende Gesichtsmerkmale, sondern auch große Fingerknöchel und sowas, weil irgendwann die Wachstumszwischenräume, die haben ein gewisses Maximum bei Menschen. Du brauchst ja, um zu wachsen, Zwischenräume ändern. Deswegen, um zu gucken, wie groß dein Kind wird, kannst du die Hand röntgen lassen und dann siehst du, wie gross die Zwischenräume sind zwischen den Knochen und dann kannst du sehen, wie gross das wird. Das kann man sehr früh rausfinden. Deswegen gibt es bei Menschen eine Maximalgrösse. Und wenn ein Mensch aber immer noch wächst, weil irgendwas auf die Hypophyse drückt, auf die Hormone, das ist eine endokrine Krankheit, kann man ja mal sagen. Was geht denn bei dir eigentlich ab? Du hast heute Morgen schon Hypophysie gesagt. Wo kommt das her? Ich käme mich damit aus. Warum? Weil ich, weil das bei mir gemessen wurde, weil ich sehr gross war schon, sehr früh, dachte man sich, wow, ist es ein Erzieher oder ist es noch ein Kindergartenkind? Und dann hat man die Hand geröntgt, ich habe mir das alles erklärt. Bei mir war es mal andersrum. Ich habe meinen Zivildienst mit Kindern geleistet und dann saß ich auch am ersten Tag am Tisch und dann saß ich da rum und alle haben das Essen bekommen und das Kind neben mir fragt, hey, wer ist denn das neue Kind? Okay, nice, Autorität schon mal direkt im Keller, einfach nice, ich wieg einfach das Vierfache davon, irgendwie, trag drei Brillen irgendwie, hab Abitur und er so, wer ist denn das neue Kind? Fuck you, einfach, der geht rum. Aber bei Schlangen ist es ja nichts, Schlangen werden ja immer grösser. Die werden einfach immer, immer grösser und es werden sie auch teilweise manchmal richtig groß, 20 Meter lang und riesen dick. Weil sie alt sind einfach. Ja, weil die einfach nie aufhören zu wachsen. Wie geil ist das denn, weil die halt die sich halt immer häuten und dann einfach eine neue Haut kriegen. Wie cool das auch wäre, wenn die ältesten Menschen die grössten wären, so dann sieht man genau, wie Menschen sind, wie alt Menschen sind. Na, wir haben ein bisschen sperrig, oder? Ne, ich finde das immer cool, wenn so die ganz alten Menschen kaum mehr gehen können, einfach so, die viel, auch wenn die der U-Bahn dann umkippen, weil die manchmal noch nicht an der Stange sind, um sie festhalten zu können, dass einfach so drei Meter achtzig grosse Wesen sind, die man dann mit so ganz vielen kleinen Leuten aufstellen muss, auch mit so Seilen, die automatisch an denen dranhängen, auch zur Sicherheit, kann man die wieder hochbringen in so eine aufrechte Position. Mit so grossen Rollatoren ziehen die dann durch die Städte. Das wäre schon eine coole Vorstellung. Ich fände es ganz sinnvoll, ja. Fände ich auch. Ich war am Wochenende in Berlin und ich war in der Oper und das muss man mal wirklich sagen, das ist wirklich was, was man jedem mal gönnt, diese Erfahrung. Was ist meine Oper? Ja. Ich finde es, also es gibt so ein paar Gepflogenheiten, die ich ganz interessant finde. Und zwar zum einen das Husten. Ja. Also das Husten in der Oper ist wirklich, was hat mich schon da beeindruckt. Das gehört dazu. Das ist wie eine Sprache. Neben auf der Bühne ist ein eigenes Stück, aber das ganz andere Stück und das teilweise spannendere Stück spielt eigentlich im Zuschauerraum, weil irgendwann, also die Overtüre wird gespielt und irgendwann ist ein Punkt erreicht, so ab Minute zwei, wo das Publikum denkt, ach fuck it einfach und dann fängt der Alist an zu husten und dann brennt so eine Hust, so ein Epizentrum und dann von da aus gesehen sendet es so eine Hustwelle aus und das sind ja vornehmlich alte Menschen, die das dann gucken und dann rasten die komplett aus und dann husten aber alle mal ab, weil die denken, okay, ich huste jetzt ab oder unterbewusst vielleicht auch vom Stück schon mal und dann geht das wirklich los und dann sind aber alle in so einem Hustkreislauf, weil wenn man anfängt zu husten, weiß man auch oft, okay, es geht weiter jetzt, man muss weiter husten und dann das ganze Stück durch wird nur gehustet. Und wenn man hustet hat, hat man so Angst, dass man Gespräche anfängt mit anderen, so auch von der Loge herabkam, dann hustet er zurück und so, das ist ganz interessant, aber finde ich wahnsinnig cool. Und Leute, die Bravo rufen, Bravo zwischendurch. Was sind das für Menschen? Und sind es nicht eher Menschen, die selber wollen, dass ihnen mal jemand
Bravo zuruft? Ja, stimmt schon.
Es ist nicht eher so eine wahnsinnige Selbstverstellung.
Eine Steigerung dieses Phänomens
habe ich schon mal erlebt und von
vielleicht dem unsympathischsten Menschen,
den ich je aus der Ferne gesehen habe,
der nämlich, und am Ende kommen ja die ganzen
Schauspieler, im Theater war das, Schauspiel nochmal raus
und dann kam die Schauspielerin, die die Hauptrolle gespielt hat
und da hat jemand Brava gerufen. Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah denkt so, fuck you, einfach so. Weißt du, man muss einfach irgendwie, es gibt ein Level, ich habe nichts dagegen, wenn Leute Fremdworte benutzen und Hypophyse sagen oder Aristoteles zitieren und so, da habe ich an sich nichts dagegen, aber es gibt schon Level, wo man auch nicht mehr erwarten kann, dass die anderen mitziehen.
Das stimmt. Natürlich stimmt das und es wird wahrscheinlich in irgendwelchen Oper für Dummies Ratgebern auch gesagt, dass es so sein wird, aber einfach sagt, mein Gott, da kann doch niemand, das, einfach, du musst nicht allen zeigen, dass du der krass bist. Es geht nicht um dich gerade. Wo man so aus Spaß haben, wir mal angefangen, uns auf Latein zu begrüssen. Weil es ist so schön bieder, salve. Und dann gab es aber diesen einen, der Latein besonders ernst nimmt aus der Klasse, der dann immer Salvete gesagt hat, weil halt mehrere Leute da waren.
Das war genau so.
Oh, das ritt einem echt alles.
Ach Gott, aber das ist Bravo zu ruft, auch mitten im, aber ist es üblich, mitten im Stück, dass eine Arie besonders gut gesungen wurde? Überhaupt nicht, überhaupt nicht.
Dann klatscht man, fand ich schon seltsam, und dann klatscht man und dann ruft jemand Bravo!
Überhaupt nicht.
In jedem, ich habe tatsächlich mal so ein Buch durchgeblättert, in so einem, wie muss ich mich im Theater verhalten, wo muss ich in der Oper steht, immer ganz in Fett, du hältst deine fucking Fresse und deine Hände still, bis das Stück vorbei ist. Klar, natürlich bei Opern mit Aufzügen und Vorhängen und Pause und so, vor der Pause kurz klatschen, aber nicht wertend, also nicht, je besser dir das Gefallen, desto länger klatschen, sondern bei der Pause kurz abklatschen, zack, dann Pause und am Ende kannst du klatschen, so viel du willst, lange Ding gedönst. Vor der Pause war das auch ganz seltsam, da kamen die halt nochmal raus. Also da kamen schon die ersten nochmal raus und haben sich schon verbeugt. Ach was. Und zwar Hauptdarsteller, die halt danach auch noch eine Rolle gespielt haben. Das ist ja mega scheiße. Das ist total der Bruch auch in der Version. Mega, mega. Und dann war halt gerade eine Frau, die von ihrem Mann beim Fremdgehen erwischt wurde.
Und dann kamen die beiden, die sich gerade gegenseitig hassen, offensichtlich, kamen Hand in Hand raus und haben sich verbeugt. Ach, wie lame ist das denn? Und die Person, die gerade gestorben ist, kommt nochmal raus so, ich glaube, die kommt nochmal im Stück. Mit so einem Messer im Bauch. Nervig. Ja, fand ich mega nervig. Aber das war echt interessant. Also ich habe eine Oper gesehen, die war so mega modern, es war Zauberflöte, was ganz seltsam war, weil es ist eigentlich dieses super bunte, altmodische Stück mit diesen tollen, großen Kleidern und so. Das war halt mega modern, habe ich mal in so einer ganz postmodernen Version gesehen und halt jetzt der Maskenball von Verdi, was echt ein strange Stück ist. Auch weil es nicht so, ich muss sagen, Le Miserable hat mehr Tiefe gehabt, also wirklich durchaus mehr Tiefe.
Wie meint es, von der Handlung oder was? Von der Handlung, von der ganzen, also Le Miserable hatte ich inzwischen echt Probleme mit dem Ganzen zu folgen, weil noch ein Charakter reinkam, noch ein Charakter reinkam und so und das alles irgendwie so geschichtlich auch ganz interessant war, aber der Maskenball null. Das ist wirklich, ein Mann will umgebracht, also ein König wird umgebracht werden, dann steht er aber auf...
Will umgebracht werden?
Nee, soll umgebracht werden, wird ein Anschlag auf den geplant, er plant einen Maskenball, steht aber heimlich auf die Freundin seiner besten Freundin, seines besten Freundes, da kommt so eine Wahrsagerin ins Spiel, die sagt, der Freund wird ihn umbringen, alle lachen, ha ha ha, Freund bringt ihn um, weil er mit seiner Freundin erwischt wird. Also ganz, ganz einfaches, seltsames Stück. Ja, manchmal muss der Plot gar nicht so kompliziert sein. Nein, muss gar nicht so kompliziert sein. Aber leider auch, also ganz, man erwartet ja immer so eine Unzugänglichkeit. Das will ich damit sagen. Man hat manchmal ein bisschen Angst, weil es so unzugänglich sein könnte, ist es nicht. Aber zum Thema Applaus und Applausordnung, es gab mal die Situation in der Sowjetunion auf dem Höhepunkt der großen politischen Morde und irgendwie jeder in der Partei wurde verdächtigt, Dissertanddeternat gewesen zu sein und überall wurden Leute erschossen und überall war Paranoia und Spione und irgendwie die ganze Partei wurde gesäubert. Gab es mal die Situation, dass nach einem Vortrag von irgendeinem Parteifunktionär die ganze Gruppe natürlich aufgestanden ist und applaudiert hat und gejubelt hat und niemand aufhören wollte zu klatschen. Weil man natürlich nicht der Erste sein wollte, der aufhört zu klatschen, weil das zeigt natürlich, dass du den Vortrag nicht so toll fandest. Und es war die Situation, dass wirklich minutenlang Leute standen und geklatscht haben und es einfach nicht aufgehört hat. Es tut auch irgendwann echt weh. Ja, aber du musst dir auch wirklich richtig alles geben, weil natürlich auch Leute beobachtet haben, wer klatscht da nicht. So genauso wie du bei Nazis geguckt hast, wer macht keinen Hitlergruss, der war am nächsten Tag weg. Und da ist natürlich auch klar, wer macht da nicht so mit, wer grönt nicht so laut. Und dadurch bist du manchmal in so einer Sackgassensituation, dass die einfach nicht aufhören, weil niemand aufhören will. Und tatsächlich war es so, nach 20 Minuten oder so hat dann irgend so ein Firmenvorsteher aufhört zu klatschen, alle anderen aufgehört, der Typ war
für zehn Jahre im Gulag. Ja, einfach
verloren. Aber irgendjemand muss
halt aufhören. Du kannst halt nicht
den Rest des Regimes klatschen.
Also auch da, das ist einfach so ein
weirdes System, das irgendwann einfach in so
eine Sackgasse kommt. Aber da merkt man doch, bei sowas
merkt man doch, dass das politische System
für ein Arsch ist. Einfach, dass es
komplett das Falsche ist, wenn man sich in so Sackgassen manövriert. Ja, klar, aber das ist halt auch für ein Arsch ist, einfach. Dass es komplett das Falsche ist,
wenn man sich in so Sackgassen manövrieren lässt.
Ja klar, aber das ist halt auch ein, weißt du, das passiert halt
manchmal, da gehen halt Leute drauf, die es nicht verdienen, aber im
grossen Ganzen ist es halt, glaube ich, in der Denkweise so
fuck it. Das ist wirklich schlecht.
Das war einfach so eine ganz
unangenehme Situation, weil
er ist eigentlich der Held, er ist
eigentlich für alle anderen gestorben, weil
zehn Jahre in Haft gekommen, und fast gestorben wahrscheinlich.
Wie lange würde das denn gehen? Weil man klatscht jemand leise.
Nee, du darfst nicht leise klatschen, sobald du leise klatscht, bist du Verräter.
Na ja.
Guck mal, wie gut ich gerade klatsche.
Ich sehe das sehr laut.
Hört ihr was?
Ja gut, du hast natürlich recht. Du wärst, glaube ich, ein guter Kommerz gewesen.
Nee, abgefahren.
Ach ja, irgendwann war ich im Museum auch, dann, das war echt ein cooles Museum auf der Museumsinsel, wo man diese Ägyptenabteilung hat, wo auch Nofretete steht. Ich weiß nicht, dieses neue Museum oder so heißt das, glaube ich einfach. Wie, so eine Nachbildung oder was? Nee, Nofretete steht da. Die echte Mumie oder was? Ja, diese Maske der Nofretete halt. Ah ja, die Totenmaske, oder was? Die Totenmaske, genau. Und dann gibt es da diese coole Abteilung, wo diese ganzen Sarkoferge stehen und diese ganzen alten Steintafeln und diese ägyptischen Figuren und sowas. Und man kennt ja, wenn man an Ägypten denkt, denkt man ja immer an die Sphinx, die keine Nase mehr hat. Und man denkt, haha, lustige Geschichte, haha, Asterix, Matti bestimmt, Obelix. Und dann guckt man mal in die, durch die Reihen im Museum und dann habe ich eine Figur entdeckt, die auch keine Nase hatte und dann habe ich mich mal umgesehen und noch zehn andere Figuren gesehen, die alle keine fucking Nase haben. Und dann habe ich mal geguckt, wo man anders liegen könnte, habe es googelt und die erste Erklärung hat sich ein bisschen leicht gemacht, weil die hat gesagt, ja gut, die sind alle sehr alt und irgendwann werden die mal alle vorne übergekippt sein und auf die Nase gefallen sein. Und dann ist die weg. Und die andere Erklärung war, dass die Ägypter dachten, dass die ganze Energie, die Lebensenergie in der Nase steckt und wenn die nicht wollten, dass jemand wieder aufersteht, haben die die Nase abgeschlagenchlagen, beziehungsweise seine Totennachbildung in die Nase abgeschlagen. Aber entweder müssen Ägypter also per Definition alle mega die Säcke gewesen sein, weil sie ihre Leute gehasst haben. Also alle unbeliebt sein oder wahnsinnig schusselig, dass sie alle immer vorne überfallen lassen. Aber repräsentiert denn die Sphinx eine konkrete Person oder ist es eine Art Gottheit? Ist es eine Art Katze oder nicht? Ja, das weiß ich nicht genau. Ja, es ist eine Art Katze. Die Gottheiten sehen ja immer aus wie Tiere. Ja. Aber ich weiß nicht genau, weil die ja, vielleicht Ich würde sagen, dass die Nase einfach das exprimierendste Teil des Kopfes ist und halt irgendwann die es abweicht. Nee, nee, aber die haben auch so krasse, die haben auch so richtig krasse Kopfgeschmücke teilweise, auch so mega ausdefinierte Haare, wo man denkt, wie kann das, es kann unmöglich gehalten haben, aber die Nase ist weg. Die sind einfach, alle Nasen sind weg. Ich dachte immer, es wäre ein Sphinx-Problem, es ist einfach ein Ägypter-Problem. Wo sind die Nasen hin? Barely any noses. Aber stimmt das mit diesen ganzen Fallen bei den Pyramiden und so, oder ist es Hollywood, oder haben die wirklich Fallen gebaut für Grabräuber? Ich glaube, die hat eine wahnsinnige Angst vor Grabräuber. Ja, aber ich finde es so merkwürdig, dass man das alles so vorausplant. Weil man denkt ja auch so, die Pyramide ist ja mitten in der Stadt, wo die leben, oder nicht? Die liegt ja nicht irgendwo am anderen Ende der Welt, so wie es mit Jana Jones, die haben da ja gewohnt. Und was für von die Riesenstädten. Ja, und die Pyramide wird ja auch bewacht werden und so. Du hast ja jetzt auch nicht irgendwie beim Reichstag in Berlin irgendwie so Fallen vor dem Kanzlerzimmer. Falls du die Kanzlerin umbringen willst, musst du durch irgendwelche Schlangengruben durch. Die sind ja bewacht von mobilen Menschen. Also warum denn immer diese Fallen bauen? Als ob die dachten, dass sie untergehen. Ja eben, die müssen ja gedacht haben, falls wir mal alle ausgestorben sind, wow, wow, wow, wow, we're gonna stop you there, warum sollen wir aussterben, naja, falls irgendwie der Nil überfließt und wir alle ertrinken, wow, was ist das denn?
Diese Mumien, dieses wir müssen es mumifizieren für die Nachwelt, dieses komplette Fixieren auf das, was nach dem Tod ist, die haben ja mehr Zeit damit verbracht, irgendwie Leute zu mumifizieren, als mit Körperhygiene oder so einen Scheiß. Glaubst du, je beschissener ein Leben in der Gesellschaft ist, desto größer ist der Kult im Leben nach dem Tod? Weiß nicht, die hatten, glaube ich, ein ganz gutes Leben. Meinst du, echt die Ägypter? Klar. Die hatten ja total Beschissens im Samen den ganzen Tag. Nee, hatten die ja nicht mehr im Nil gelebt, wo ja auch alles grün war und so, haben krasse Städte gehabt, die haben krasse Infrastruktur gehabt, die haben fast alles erfunden, die haben Hygiene, haben die tatsächlich sehr gross geschrieben, die hatten kaum Krankheiten, die hatten ein ganz gutes politisches System, die waren ganz schön am Start. Und dann dachte ich auch, warum sind die dann untergegangen, aber die haben irgendwie zweitausend Jahre gelebt. Ja, länger als du. Länger als ich. Länger als die Deutschen. Die gibt es noch nicht so lange. Das stimmt. Die waren schon ganz so fast. Weißt du, wir gehen irgendwann unter, also oder Europa oder so, man kann sich das mal nicht vorstellen. Deswegen finde ich es so merkwürdig, dass die immer davon ausgegangen sind, weil man denkt ja schon, das System, das man hat, das ist das Beste, weil du kannst dir nichts vorstellen, was danach kommt. Ja, ist auch die Frage, wie sehr man Bock hat, Dinge für die Nachwelt aufzuheben. Auch diese ganze, wie gesagt, diese ganze Grabräuber-Prophylaxe, dieses ganze Malen auf Stein, dieses, die haben ja auch Papyrus gehabt und so. Das war alles unfassbar haltbar. So als ob die wussten, wir gehen unter, aber ihr könnt alles von uns nachgucken. Aber ist das jetzt nicht irgendwie so rückwärts konstruiert, sind nicht die Ägypter das einzige Volk, von dem wir noch was wissen, gerade weil die so sind. Da gibt es auch andere Volker. Und alle anderen Papyrus-Volker sind einfach weg, von denen wissen wir nichts. Die Imker und so. Die Imker. Entschuldigung. Die Imker, die haben in Honig geschrieben. Da habe ich mich ganz kurz disqualifiziert für jegliche historische Diskussion. Aber ich hätte vielleicht noch, wo wir gerade was vom Theater hatten, vielleicht noch einen Platz eins zu unserer Walk of Shame. Denn es ist ja so, beim Theater gehst du ja raus und verbeugst dich ganz am Ende und dann gehst du wieder hinter den Vorhang und wenn die Leute noch klatschen, geht man noch mal raus und verbeugt sich. Und ich habe aber selber ein paar mal so Laientheater gespielt und dann bist du hinter dem Vorhang und musst dir mal abschätzen, klatschen die jetzt noch genug, um noch mal raus zu gehen oder nicht? Und es war ein paar mal so, du gehst raus und in dem Moment, in dem du den ersten Fuß auf die Bühne setzt, hören die auf zu klatschen und du bist aber schon rausgelaufen und läufst nochmal raus in ein komplett stilles Publikum und verbeugst sich und die so, ach so, jetzt klatschen zwei Leute, die Eltern, die Eltern klatschen. Ja, jetzt nochmal, hä, Q&A oder gibt's Poster oder was? Irgendwas, verbeugst du dich nochmal und rennst so schnell es geht weg. Das Allerschlimmste, ja. Bei professionellen Theatern ist es ja so, dass der Vorhang aufgehalten wird, wenn man wieder zurückgeht. Weil manchmal wird man auch vor geschlossenen Vorhang, wird der davor verbeugt. Und dann war das bei mir aber so, dass niemand sich irgendwie dafür verantwortlich gefühlt hat, den Vorhang aufzuhalten. Und du findest, weil das ist der Plan eines Vorhangs, die Öffnung nicht! Dann stehst du da, hast dich gerade verbeugt, aber im besten Moment, wow, alle, Oma hatänen in den Arm und du gehst so langsam zurück und dann, ja okay, dann läufst du einfach in den geschlossenen Vorhang, dann drehst du dich um und suchst wie wild, suchst einfach in diesem grossen, schweren Samtvorhang, wo es so eine Öffnung findest du nicht. Das ist das Problem. Ach, Showbusiness, Theater, die Bretter, die die Welt bedeuten, das ist schon was Feines. Ich habe echt überlegt, ob ich Theater spielen anfangen soll. Ich habe echt Bock drauf, mal wieder. Wollen wir in der Theatergruppe teilnehmen? Ja, ich habe wirklich Lust drauf, das mal wieder zu machen. Ich will es aber nicht professionell machen. Wenn ihr irgendwo in Köln eine geile Leittheatergruppe kennt oder habt oder so, oder seid. Ich kenne auch sogar ein paar Leute, dann lasst es mal hingehen, einfach. Ich habe leider nicht so viel Zeit, aber an sich kann es schon ganz cool werden. Einen Tag abends oder so, weiß nicht, einfach mal hingehen, ein bisschen mitproben, so ein kleines Stück, irgendwie so eine Nebenrolle spielen, da habe ich schon mal Lust drauf. Ist auch nicht schlecht, ist ja auch so eine Kunst, das ist komplett Vergänglich, die führt man einmal auf und dann ist es weg. So wie Tanz oder, oh, da kommt ein Zettel rein von unserer Redaktion, kommt gerade ein Zettel rein. Es kam gerade ein Zettel rein, das war lustig, mir wäre beinahe die Tasse aus der Hand gefallen. Oh, wunderbar, vielen Dank an die
Beobachtung, der da draußen
aus einer komischen
gesprungenen Scheibe kam. Aber ist ja so ein bisschen,
ist das eine Rebellion gegen diese ganze
Digitalisierung, gegen dieses Posten
auf Instagram? Das Theater rebelliert glaube ich nicht.
Ich glaube, etwas nicht rebelliert ins Theater.
Ich habe alles andere rebelliert gegen das Theater,
aber ich glaube nicht,
ich weiß nicht, ob das, aber ja, also es ist schon mal cool, wieder was Vergängliches zu haben. Also ich finde es auch cool, dass man nicht Dinge manchmal nicht fotografieren darf und so, sondern einfach mal dann am Start sein muss. So, das finde ich schon ganz cool. Ja, finde ich auch. Vergänglichkeit. Ja, wir konservieren gerade alles. Ja, diese Instagram-Kultur finde ich scheiße. Das ist ein bisschen blöd zu sagen, ne? Aber ist schon okay. Man kann mal auch eine Meinung haben, die andere auch schon geäußert haben. Ja. Das ist erlaubt. Aber ich habe überlegt, ich erlebe jetzt mal wieder mehr am Wochenende. Also Berlin, der Berlin-Tripper hat schon viel erlebt. Bist du halt einfach alleine noch? Nee, nee, ich musste da auch für die Uni so ein Interview führen mit einem Zeitungsmenschen. Aha. Ja, das war ultra spannend. Wow. Am Girlie. Am Girlie? Ja, da habe ich leider die Fehler gemacht. Einmal Barbie Girl, sage ich oft. Da habe ich zu lange jemanden angeguckt, der mir offensichtlich Koks verkaufen wollte. Ah. Und wenn du den zu lange anguckst, dann denken die, der will offensichtlich,
was auch eine relativ beschränkte
Weltsicht ist, so, ich weiß nicht,
was er verkauft, aber ich habe ihn angeguckt und das ist ein Fehler.
Weil dann denken die, du willst was von dem kaufen.
Ja. Und dann
gucken die dich an wiederum und
denken dann, du wärst mit denen so eine
Blickkonversation und gucken dich wiederum so
an, dass du die weiter anguckst und so
und beide haben keine Ahnung, was der andere will und dann ist ist er sehr lange hinter mir hergelaufen, wollte mir Koks verkaufen. Und dann ist er in der Verfungsjagd ausgebrochen irgendwie. Dann bin ich halt weggelaufen und habe dann das Interview gemacht. Aber er war auf Koks, er war schneller. Ja, er war nicht schnell. Miu, in so einem brennenden Schweif er mir vorbeigelaufen. Aber auf dem Weg zurück im Zug saß vor mir eine Mutter, eine junge Mutter mit ihrem Sohn Jason. Es war so ein bisschen Programm, er hat mich auch immer getreten, hat dann geguckt, wie ich das finde und ich war begeistert. Also mein Gesicht hat Begeisterung ausgestrahlt, aber die Mutter war clever, sie hat nämlich, sie hat ihn manchmal geschlagen, und dann hat sie manchmal eine sehr spannende Drohung ausgesprochen, sie hat nämlich gesagt, Jason, du hörst es auf, den Jungen zu treten, sonst hole ich den Luftballon raus. Okay. Und weder Jason noch ich wussten so, wir haben beide so gleich geguckt, die Mutter an. Will ich wissen, was der Luftballon ist? Will ich den Luftballon? Und ich dachte, er hat sofort aufgehört. Was ist zwischen den beiden vorgefallen, dass der Luftballon Jason so eine Angst macht? Krass. Schreibt es in die Kommentare. Ich würde es echt gerne wissen. Oder heisst es sowas wie, sonst, weiss ich nicht, denn die Strafe ist Spaß. Ey, das war so eine ganz alternative Ernstungsmethode, keine Ahnung. Aber was ist das denn für eine Art von Strafe? Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie vielleicht vor der Fahrt einfach so ein Luftballon aufgeblasen hat, da so ein Gesicht drauf gemalt hat. Mit Jasons Gesicht drauf gemalt. Und dann so, das bist du und dann so ein Nadel und pop. Und das bist du in Hamm-Westfalen. Ja. Bam. Schlecht. Nee, war nicht so schlecht, das fand ich echt ganz lustig. Jason. Aber die Erziehungsmethoden sind echt ganz spannend, da steigt man auch nicht nur so ganz durch. Da war neben mir, da waren auch so eine Familie mit Kindern und die haben gerade Mathe gelernt oder sowas. Und dann hat der Vater, die waren noch sehr klein und konnten kaum Mathe, und dann hat der Vater immer sowas gefragt, was ist denn zwei plus drei? Neun? Richtig. Was ist denn zwei mal sechs? Zehn? Richtig. Und das ging stundenlang. Und was ist da der Plan dahinter? Ich verstehe, ich war kurz davor zu sagen, nein, das war alles falsch, die Antworten waren neun, zwölf, drei, sieben und Wurzel aus drei. Was ist denn das Problem mit euch? Was ist denn der Plan dahinter? Vielleicht hat man sowas wie die Freude am Lernen, dass man einfach mal sagt, dass die Mathe mit positiven Gefühlen verbindet oder so. Aber ist die Freude nicht immer vorbei, wenn man denkt, ja, ich kann jetzt offensichtlich, Mathe habe ich durchgespielt, ich kann alles, alle Lösungen sind richtig.
Ich meine, vielleicht merken die sich gar nicht das, was sie sagen, sondern sie merken sich nur das Gefühl in dem Stadium oder so und dann verbinden sie das mit irgendwie Zuspruch oder so.
Und ich fand das so falsch, weil im ganzen Zug haben so die Augen liege.
So alle werden so skeptisch, so Moment mal, zweimal sechs ist doch nichts.
Alles, was ich jemals gesch...
Und auch die Leute, die Geschäftsmodelle haben angefangen, ihre Excel-Tabellen zu lesen. Delete, delete, verkaufen, verkaufen, verkaufen! Die ganzen Zahlen stehen nicht. An alles, was ich jemals geglaubt habe. Alles stimmt nie mehr. Stimmt schon. Das fand ich ganz seltsam. Bei mir war es letztens ganz komisch mit dem Zug gefahren und man weiß, das ist immer so eine Frage, ist man ein guter Mensch oder nicht, weil da war so ein Zug und das war wirklich so, als hätte jemand den ganzen Zug genommen und so seitlich geneigt und alle Menschen wären auf eine Seite gefallen. Auf der einen Seite des Zuges waren alle Plätze leer, dann wurden die immer voller, voller, voller und auf der anderen Seite waren sie so voll, dass die Leute gestehen sind und irgendwie überall auf dem Boden saßen und irgendwie rumgesassen. Warum sind die Leute gestanden und haben nicht gesagt, ich gehe jetzt auf den Platz. Weil die wahrscheinlich nicht wussten, dass auf der anderen Seite des Zuges die Plätze frei sind. Achso, du meinst hinten und vorne oder meinst direkt links? Ja genau, hinten und vorne, Ende und Anfang des Zuges, so. Ich dachte gerade ja. Und ich war am Ende und habe einen freien Sitzplatz gehabt und bin nach vorne gelaufen, um mir irgendwie schön doppelseitiges Snickers irgendwie meine Mundfresse zu schieben. Florentins Essenstagebuch. Macht mit auf tumblr.com. Und bin durch alle durchgelaufen und hab halt gesehen, dass da ganz viele Leute stehen und halt irgendwie dann aufeinandersetzen und so und ich hab mir immer so, ist das jetzt meine Pflicht, ihnen zu sagen, dass auf der anderen Seite noch ganz viel frei ist oder nicht? Oh, da kommt noch mehr. Dankeschön, unsere, oh, da wäre heute eine fantastische Redaktion. Oh ne, ich will die Beeren. Das ist ja clever, Gummibären, so wie Erdbeeren und bald Frucht. Ja, denk mal an Lachgummi und Weingummi, denk da man aber nach. Ja, die Frisse. So, auf jeden Fall war es dann die Situation, dass ich nicht genau wusste, wie ich mich verhalten soll. Und ich habe dann überlegt, oder kommt noch mehr, kommt noch mehr? Dankeschön, oh, ein Snickers! Wer ist das denn? Ich weiß wirklich nicht. Und 22 Cent. Hier reicht uns gerade irgendeine mysteriöse Hand in unser Aufnehmenkabinchen. Ja, meine Mutter hat gesagt, wenn sie mit eins gelernt hat, dann soll sie keine Süßigkeiten von Fremden annehmen. Ich glaube, sie hat auch gesagt, dass durch das kaputte Fenster, das gesprungene Fenster Süßigkeitenpakete reicht. Na, auf jeden Fall, ich wusste nicht und ich habe mich dann dazu entschieden, ich bin dann durchgelaufen und habe dann den Ersten gesagt so, auf der anderen Seite ist noch viel Platz, aber ich habe es dann irgendwann noch aufgehört, weil du kannst nicht hundert Leuten sagen. Oder du gehst zu den Leuten, wo kaum jemand sitzt und sagst denen, da hinten ist alles voll und gehst wieder. Du machst einfach, wo war es das ausgelöst? Ja, aber es war dann so, ich wollte dann nicht so arrogant, also ich hatte mir immer so Angst, arrogant zu wirken, deswegen habe ich immer so getan, als würde ich mich an den Leuten so ganz unangenehm eng vorbeidrücken und dann aus so einer Gehässigkeit her so raus so, ja, aber auf der anderen Seite ist immer noch Platz so, mir war es lieber, aus einer Gehässigkeit es denen zu sagen, so dass ich das Arschloch bin. Das ist sehr deutsch. Ja, aber nee, aber damit Sie die Chance haben, Ihre mangelnde Kompetenz der Zugfahrt, Ärger auf mich zu spiegeln, dass sie sich nicht selber eingestehen müssen, oh jetzt bin ich ja doof da. Weil ich kenne es nämlich, wenn mir jemand helfen will, dann reagiere ich trotzig und sage, nee, brauche ich nicht. Wenn ich ganz viel in der Hand habe, so am Supermarkt und dann die Frau sagt, ja, brauche ich eine Tüte, dann sage ich erst recht, nein, brauche ich nicht. So, das ist scheiße und irgendwie total spontan und intuitiv. Aber um den Leuten das zu ermöglichen, habe ich die Arschlochrolle genommen, damit sie das nicht machen müssen. Kennst du das Gefühl im Kino, dass du hoffst, dass jemand auf deinem Platz sitzt? Ja, das ist das schönste Gefühl der Welt. Und dann im Zug auf deinem reservierten Platz. Ich hoffe, und das ist so deutsch und so scheiße, aber ich hoffe, dass da jemand sitzt auf meinem Platz, dem ich sagen kann, mein schönes Sitze ist auf meinem Platz.
Ja, ich war am Wochenende auf dem Gästelisse Geisterbahn Live-Podcast tatsächlich in Köln und es war echt cool.
Und da hat Donny erzählt, dass es ihm immer, wenn er mit dem Zug fährt, total unangenehm ist und dass er hofft, dass niemand auf dem Platz sitzt, den er reserviert hat, weil es ihm immer so unangenehm ist, die Leute anzusprechen.
Ich dachte mir, nein, du hast es nicht verstanden. Du hast Comedy nicht verstanden. Das ist doch das Wunderschöne, in dem du hast Deutschsein nicht verstanden. So, du gehst dann nicht mehr, bitte lass ihn da sitzen und dann so, Entschuldigung, das ist mein Platz und dann in diese leeren, weil die Leute setzen sich ja hin und denken sich, oh, ich hab einen Sitzplatz, dann in der nächsten Haltestelle kommen alle und setzen alle leeren Plätze noch frei und dann denkt er sich, fuck, jetzt kann ich mich nicht mehr umsetzen und denkt dann, scheiße, hätte ich mich woanders hingesetzt. Und das ist das Schönste, so dieses Rechthaben. Oder noch ein gutes Gefühl ist, wenn du nur eine Sache im Supermarkt hast, wie ein Wasser kaufst, dann stelle ich mich immer an die Kasse, wo jemand davor ist, mit den meisten Gegenständen, der immer sagt, gehen Sie doch vorbei, weil man halt nur eine Sache hat in der Hand. Dann sagen ja oft Leute, wollen Sie nicht vor, weil ich habe so viel, dann wird man vorgelassen. Wie cool wäre ein Flashmob, wo ganz viele Leute mit nur einer Sache in der Hand stehen und dann an dem vorbeigehen. Und immer so nach hinten kegeln. Ja, und dann lässt er den natürlich alle vor, er kann ja nicht irgendwann sagen, Schluss, dich mit einem Gegenstand lasse ich noch vor, alle anderen nicht mehr. Er muss ja alle weiterlassen. Oft wurden auch schon zwei Leute vorgelassen, drei, dann muss auch vier. Aber was, wenn so unbemerkt, es werden einfach immer mehr und dann stellen sie sich auch wieder hinten an und gehen wieder ins Supermarkt. Das ist echt eine lustige Idee. Wenn er so zwei Stunden bei jemandem steht, der Leute vorbeilassen muss, weil er da nicht reinkommt. Das ist echt eine lustige Idee. Schade, dass Flashmops so ein bisschen out sind. Ja, mega. Oder auch mal Leute vorlassen, die wesentlich mehr haben als man selbst. Ich finde auch lustig, Musical ist ein Flashmop am falschen Ort. Ja. So am denkbar falschen Ort. Na gut. Das war ein bisschen Denker. Oh, ich habe eben die Nachricht bekommen, dass die Entschädigung dafür, dass in der Küche eben so viel Lärm war draußen, haben wir die Stacks bekommen jetzt. Ah, okay, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das überhaupt gehört habt, Lärm in der Küche. Wir hoffen nicht. Vielen Dank, dass ihr diese Woche auch wieder mit dabei wart bei uns, als es wieder hieß Stefan Titzler und Florian Will singen, den Podcast-Uvo. Nächste Woche gibt es eine Special-Folge, da könnt ihr euch drauf freuen, da gibt's was ganz Tolles, da gibt's nämlich eine kleine autobiografische Folge.
Ah, machen wir das nächste Woche schon?
Ja, ich würde schon sagen. Nächste Woche geht es nämlich, und da könnt ihr alle Fragen, die ihr zu dem Thema habt, könnt ihr stellen, es geht nämlich um Stefans Binky-sack-Buh-Zeit. Die Bandzeit, meine wilde Bandzeit. ähm, Bandzeit,
mittlerweile hat er seine Jungfräulichkeit wieder zurück,
aber damals ging es richtig durch,
da ging es richtig zur Sache, Frauen,
Alkohol, Erfolg, er war im Fernsehen,
Binky Sack Bu war die grosse Nummer, der angesagt ist, das ist scheiss damals und Stefan hat sich natürlich auch verändert dadurch, er erzählt uns ein bisschen aus seiner Bandzeit, ihr könnt alle Fragen stellen, wie wird man so berühmt, wie kommt man da hin, warum habt ihr euch beworben? Schreibt sie an die E-Mail-Adresse florentinwill.btf.de, einfach mal gucken, was passiert. Und wir freuen uns alle auf die nächste Folge.
Ja, schreibt alle eure Fragen, ich werde sie alle stellvertretend für euch fragen. an die E-Mail-Adresse, florentinwill at btf.de, einfach mal gucken, was wir sehen. Und wir freuen uns alle auf die nächste
Folge. Ja, schreibt alle eure Fragen, ich werde
sie alle stellvertretend für euch fragen.
Ich werde aber allen sagen, kann ich nicht darauf antworten,
aus irgendwelchen strafrechtlichen Gründen.
Boah, das war ein wilder Ritz,
habe ich auch mal gekonnt.
Bis nächste Woche!
Bis dann, wir haben, macht's gut, ciao!